When Dada first came out,
your baby's first words will be Dada, 2015.
I remember looking at the cover and going, Oh wow.
That's so smart.
That is just too good.
It's so crisp, it's so clean, it's so clear.
There's an unwritten thing
I think with moms and dads where you want the baby
to say mama or dada first.
Nancy obviously doesn't really care, but I do.
And so I was doing anything I could do
to have Winnie say dada.
So I was giving her like a bottle.
I'm like, do you want a, do you want a dada?
Like, I don't care if it's the kid's dumb.
As long as she said the dada first.
I'll let her figure out being smart later.
And then she said mama, that was her first word.
So I go, there should be a book where it's just dada,
quack, dada, moo, dada.
And you just keep saying the word dada.
And I released it and it was like, oh, that was fun,
but then.
Huge, huge record breaking bestseller.
But the best was the videos and stuff.
And the feedback from people were going like,
the kid loves reading,
the baby's laughing and you're reading a book with your baby
and I've had like teachers and go like,
you're building confidence as a child into reading
and you're making, I'm like, yes,
of course I knew that.
That was my goal all the time, you know, the whole way.
But it's like a different buzz and you get
that kind of buzz that probably teachers get where they go
like I just taught somebody something.
It's amazing.
Okay, so five more sleeps until Christmas.
We, I love this book so much.
You have dada, mama, and baby, 2015, 2017, 2019,
all best sellers.
Five More Sleeps til Christmas has broken records again,
broken records.
Knock on wood, yeah it's crazy.
And this was a very different world, as you see,
we've made our set look like the book.
This one is a different move
and it's just more for the holidays.
And I loved, you know,
I couldn't wait for Christmas and I have kids now
and they can't wait.
And it's like, how are you going to get to sleep
before Santa comes?
And I was walking Winnie home, my daughter from school.
And she goes, how many more sleeps still we go to grandma's?
And I go how many more sleeps?
That's so cute, do people say that?
Like I've never heard,
we have five more sleeps til,
I go, that's something that is so cute.
So I go, we should do five more sleeps til Christmas.
So I didn't give Winnie writing credit,
but currently our lawyers are talking
(upbeat music)